the holiday parade kicks off at downtown
summerlin this weekend jillian joins us
with a behind-the-scenes look at the
floats that will be on display this year
hey you guys so i'm really excited about
this we are getting a behind-the-scenes
look at some of the beautiful float
creations that you'll see on friday
right here at downtown summerlin haley
is back this is so cool tell me a little
bit about these floats and how many
there are we are so excited to bring
back the annual holiday parade you know
we couldn't do it last year so we're
really excited and it's really going to
be a special moment this friday we have
over seven floats inspired by your
favorite holiday movies and then the
newest one is the nutcracker so we're so
excited to unveil that one as well yeah
i was looking around at these floats
this one that our photographer lance is
showing it's all blue and there is a
sparkly chair back here what's the
inspiration for this one so this one's
inspired by frozen this is our ice
princess float and this is just one of
the very many that we have we have cast
of characters and dancers and they've
been practicing tirelessly all week to
launch it on friday yeah this is so cute
i see a nutcracker does santa get up on
any of these floats or where can you
find santa during the parade of course
the big guy himself will bring it in on
his sleigh at the very end of the parade
and then you might even catch some snow
at downtown summerlin oh i was just
saying we need a little snowfall here at
downtown summerlin so you guys are
already ahead of it and this parade
kicks off friday where and when can
people come see it every friday and
saturday through december 18th along
park center drive it'll start at the
crazy p to end and at the dining arroyo
we highly recommend getting here early
make a night of it have some dinner get
your spot on the street and enjoy the
festivities and then after the parade
you can go ice skating check out the
christmas tree and something else i'm
looking at there's a ton of bikes in
here is this what actually leads the
floats how does it work that is it's
actually really cool so they we have all
of our dancers and performers they ride
on the bikes and they actually pull the
floats through the streets of downtown
summerlin so it's really fun to see and
the kids are all cast throughout las
vegas um and so they're really excited
just to showcase their talent oh my gosh
this is so fun it's like our version of
the thanksgiving day parade but we're
getting it localized celebrating the
holidays and just how much time and work
has gone into preparing for this we've
actually been planning all the way as
back as early as march and the kids have
been rehearsing for the last couple
months
they've been in the streets we've been
you know hanging our snow machines our
music and everything and so it's just
great to see all the teams come together
work with best agency and really just
have a festive holiday tradition for the
community yeah this is really getting me
in the holiday spirit so i'm absolutely
loving this and if you guys want to come
see the floats out there on downtown
summerlin be sure to get here on friday
get early get your hot chocolate bring
your ice skates you can just have a
whole festive night ahead of you thank
you so much haley i'll send it back to
you guys